Akin: And today I
will present to you
one of the most interesting
topics in my field of study,
which is graph theory.
Um, I know the topic might
sound a little bit intimidating,
but what you need to
understand this presentation is
quite simple.
So, if you can do
the basic math,
like simple additions or
simple multiplication,
you are pretty good to go.
And what you'll need is
the observation skills
and that's probably all you
need to have for understanding
this presentation.
Before I jump in, can I ask
like, if any of you guys
have been familiar
with this topic before?
Student: A little
bit, a little bit.
Akin: Okay, um, yeah, I
hope you get something out
of today's presentation.
Hope it will be useful.
Okay.
Okay about today's agenda,
we'll go over some definitions
to see what the graph is.
And next we are
going to explore one
of the most
interesting questions
in graph theory, which is
the shortest path problem.
And then we are going
to see some examples.
And we are going to
recap it at the end.
All right.
Akin: And also feel
free to interrupt me
with any questions you may have.
Just don't be shy.
Akin: Okay.
All right.
Let's dive in.
Akin: The question
is, what is a graph?
If you have been dealing with
data before, you might have
been familiar with the concept
of graph on the left one,
you have the graph on the x axis
and y axis and the right one
you have a bar graph
to represent some data.
And but this is not the graph we
are going to talk about today.
What we are going to talk about
today is quite--a little bit
different and the definition of
it is the graph is a collection
of nodes and edges.
And by nodes here I will use the
red circle to represent a node
and the edges will be
this just a straight line.
So basically nodes can
represent any objects.
It can be people,
it can be animals,
it can be just just anything.
Akin: And the idea is to
indicate some relationships
between two nodes.
Akin: And that might
not sound clear,
but let's take a look
at some examples .
Here.
Okay, here I have a node
that represents Harvard.
Akin: And I have a node
that represents MIT.
And they both can be connected
by the edge--the space--they
are in the same
city of Cambridge.
Is it clear on this one?
Student: Yes.
Akin: All right.
Akin: And I can have a node
of Math and EECS Electrical
Engineering and
Computer Science:
and both are the
departments at MIT.
I have Akin--this is me--who
is a student at MIT and I study
math and EECS.
I can have Alice who loves
math and Bob who hates math
and Alice and Bob are rivals.
Akin: Is it good?
Student: Mmm hmm.
Akin: Okay, ah okay.
I would like to make
some notes here.
This graph is
actually quite messy.
It has like so many kinds of
nodes--you have schools you
have departments and
you also have people.
And at the same time, you also
have so many kinds of edges,
you have the same
city, have departments,
students and many more.
So, in theory,
this is not wrong.
In one graph, you can
have so many kind of nodes
and so many kind of edges.
But in practice, we
usually refer to a graph
as only having one kind of
nodes and one kind of edges.
And what it means
by that, if you
take a look at the
right graph, you
can see this graph
has nodes that
are the states in New
England and the edges
will be this indication if
two states are neighbors.
Akin: Are we still
on the same page?
Students: Mmm hmm.
Uh huh.
Akin: Yeah, and this is--I also
have some examples--you can
probably have a
better understanding.
Ah, the example I'm going to use
is the network representations.
And probably you guys
have seen Facebook before.
And what we are going to
do is Facebook actually
have a very nice way to
present the network as a graph.
And to do so you can have
the node to represent a user
and edge to represent the
friendships between any two
users.
For example, this diagram
here you can see Liz here is
has--Liz has a page
that connects to Emma,
Shane and Alan.
That means our list has
three friends, which
is Emma, Shane and Alan.
Akin: Is it--is it okay?
Is it all right?
Student: Yeah.
Akin: Okay, I just want
to ask like to make sure
that we are on the
same page like just
a quick questions like how
many friends does John have?
Student: Four?
Akin: Four.
Akin: Yeah.
Who they are?
Akin: Yeah the four
friends of John
are Bob, Jill, Shane and Leah.
Akin: Okay, still good?
Okay.
Akin: Okay, I have
another question for you.
On the right, I have a graph
whose--whose nodes are some
states in the US.
You can have Maine, New
Hampshire, Massachusetts,
and many more.
And the edges will represent
that there is a road that
connects two nodes together.
For example, this
edge is the road
that connects Maine
and New Hampshire.
This edge is the road that
connects Vermont and New York.
Akin: So basically, you can
view this graph as a map
and there are states
then they are roads
that connects states together.
Yeah.
So here's my question.
You want to drive from
Maine to Maryland, which
is this circle to this circle.
And to use a road, you need to
pay $1 for each road you take.
Yeah, the question is
that what is the cheapest
route you can take?
Akin: Any figures?
Student: You can go
along the left edges.
Akin: Left edges in New
Hampshire, Vermont, New York,
Pennsylvania and Maryland.
Student: Yeah.
Akin: Yeah, that's perfect.
And there are actually
two cheapest routes here,
which are indicated
by the green lines.
Akin: And whatever route you
take, you need to pay $5.
And this is what we call
the shortest path problem.
I will explain it
in in a minute.
But if you guys
have any questions,
if you don't understand
the graph, you can ask me.
Akin: Okay, ah, let's move on.
So, um, the shortest
path problem.
Akin: It is probably one of
the most important questions
in graph theory,
where scientists
have been dealing
with it for decades,
and it also has so many
applications in real life.
And the way we
formulate a problem
is that we are given a graph.
And we want to find the
shortest path in terms
of the number of edges
to go from one node
to another, like we just did
to go from Maine to Maryland.
Akin: And it's
actually easy to solve
by eyes if a graph is so small.
Nikita?
Did I pronounce correctly?
Student: Yep.
Akin: Yeah, he just solved
it in like 10 seconds.
And it's pretty easy
if the graph is small.
But the question is, like,
if the graph is large,
how do we do it?
Like on this one, if you
want to go from the left node
to the right node, is probably
impossible to solve it
by eyes because you know,
there are like 100 nodes
and thousand edges.
So to solve these problems,
computer scientists
have come up with very nice
and very simple procedures
to find a shortest path.
And we call it the breadth
first search or BFS for short.
Okay.
Akin: And we are
going to do it now.
And I'm going to list the
instructions on the left,
and we are going to solve
it together, on the right.
Akin: So to do it,
we are going to start
with labeling the start node,
which is Maine here with zero.
And then you're going
to see that from Maine,
you can expand to New Hampshire.
Akin: So we're going to
put 1 at New Hampshire.
Akin: And then
from New Hampshire,
you can only go to
Vermont and Massachusetts.
So we will put 2 here.
And if you do the same thing
from Vermont and Massachusetts,
you can only go to New York,
Connecticut and Rhode Island,
and we put 3 there.
Akin: And we are going to do it
again and again until we find
Maryland, Akin: which is 5.
Akin: Is it clear
on the procedure?
Students: Yeah.
Akin: That's good.
Okay, so um, We
found Maryland, it's
level five, meaning that to
go from Maine to Maryland,
you need to take five edges.
However, these
procedures only tell you
how like the number, the
least number of edges
you need to take.
But it doesn't exactly
tell you like what path
you should be taking.
So the question
is, how do you find
such a path that costs you $5?
And the answer is what
we call backtracking.
And it is quite simple too.
So what it means by backtracking
is that you have Maryland at 5
and you have Maine at 0.
You want to find a path that
goes like 5-4-3-2-1 and 0.
And to do that, on the left
one, you can go 5-4-3-2-1 and 0
and under right one you can go
5-4-3-2-1 and 0 and these are
actually two paths that we
just saw it earlier by eyes.
Akin: is it clear for everyone?
Students: Yes.
Akin: Okay, sounds good.
So, how do you guys
feel about this example?
Is it like, too hard
to easy or just okay?
Student: It's all right.
Akin: It's all right?
All right for everybody?
Okay, um, if this is
not too hard for you,
I have two questions that might
be a bit more challenging.
For this one, you
still have a map.
You have to have the same graph
with the nodes of the states.
And but now, each road
will cost you differently.
Like for example, from
Maine to New Hampshire,
it will cost you $1.
And from New Hampshire
to Massachusetts,
it will cost you $2.
So basically, it's like
the numbers above the edge
to tell you the
amount of money you
need to pay for using the road.
Akin: You still want to
go from Maine to Maryland?
Akin: Will you still
pick the same route?
Akin: I'll tell you here that
the old one will cost you
$11--or $1, $2, $3, $3 and $2.
Akin: Yeah, can we do better?
Student: I think in the
lower part of the graph,
we can take the right route
this time, so it would cost $4.
Akin: Yeah.
Akin: Yeah, that's a good catch.
If you go this way, you only
need to pay four, right?
Student: Mmm hmm.
Akin: How about the upper part?
Akin: Can you find the
shorter way, the cheaper way?
Student: Well, we can go from
New Hampshire to Massachusetts
to Connecticut to New York.
Akin: Yeah, that's great.
This is actually the
cheapest path we can buy.
Akin: So, this type of
question, we call it
the weighted shortest
path problem, is basically
the shortest path problem
with some variations.
So it--here every edge will
have the corresponding weight.
In this case, the way is
just the amount of toll
we need to pay for
using the road.
Akin: Is everybody still good?
Okay.
Akin: So, as you can see,
the traditional breadth
first search will not
work on this graph
because it will just tell us
to go on this way, the old way.
But the actual the
actual cheapest route
is just to go on the green line.
So the question is
like ah, how can we
solve it by using the BFS?
Akin: The answer is we need
to do some modifications.
To use the BFS to solve it, we
can add an intermediate node
here.
So we basically can
split up the roads.
And so from one road
that cost you $2
is going to be split
up into two roads that
cost you $1 for each road.
Akin: Is the diagram
clear for you?
Student: Yeah.
Akin: Yeah.
And also the same thing
with a road that cost you $3
can be split into three
roads that cost you $1 each.
And you can transform the graph
from the graph with the weights
to the graph with
intermediate nodes.
As you can see, Massachusetts to
Rhode Island--$2 will be split
into two roads and you can do
the same for every single edge.
Akin: And from here,
you can use the BFS
like we just did before.
I'm going to just
show you how it goes
because it will take too long.
You have 0-1-2-3-4-5-6-7-8-9.
Akin: And you can
do the backtracking
to find the actual
shortest path.
Akin: Is it clear for everybody?
Student: Yep.
Akin: Yeah, sounds good.
Okay.
I'd like to end with some--a
couple of examples that you may
have come across.
So, these are the
actual examples
in real life of the BFS.
So the first one is the
cheapest flight transits.
If you have used some
traveling engines before, like,
you will want to go from
one place to another.
But if you do a search,
we will tell you
what is the cheapest
route but it's a transit.
So in this model, you are given
the origin and destination
and price of several flights.
And for example, here you
want to go from Boston
to Los Angeles.
You can use the
breadth first search
to see that this is actually
the cheapest route you can find.
And another example
that I have here
is the minimizing
the signal delay.
So if you want to call a
friend--like Alice wants
to call Bob, wants to call Bob,
so the signal's actually going
to bounce off a lot of
cellphone towers and to reaching
the destination and from the
signal to go from one tower
to another tower,
it has some delays.
So we can we can
model this as a graph
with the node to be the cell
phone towers and the edge
to represent the delays
from tower to tower.
And we can use the
breadth first search
to see like what should be
the fastest route that signal
actually minimize the delay.
Yeah.
Akin: Is the example
clear to everybody?
Student: Yep.
Akin: Yeah.
That's pretty much
all I have for today.
Just want to recap
everything up.
Today we learned
what the graph is.
And we see how to
solve the shortest path
problems by the breadth
first search, but on the one
without the weight
and weighted on.
And we also saw some
applications in real life
like route planning
and minimizing delays.
Akin: And yeah, that's
all I have for today.
You guys have any questions?
I'll be happy to answer it.
Student: I think
everything is clear.
Student: Yeah.
Clear for me too.
No questions from me.
Student: Same.
Akin: That's, yeah,
that's all I have today.
Thank you.
Thank you, you guys.